[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر بركه
احييكم وهذه العربيه 360 حيث الخبر من كل
زواياه هو من جميع جوانبه
خطاب صوتي لبوتين يعلن فيه الحرب الواسعه
على اوكرانيا الكرملين
النووي
[تصفيق]
اشتباكات دارفور تخلف قتلى وجرحى واوروبا
تتوعد معرقلي السلام في السودان بعقوبات
ولدينا ايضا
مجلس شيوخ الامريكي يدقق بامتثال تويتر
لمعايير الخصوصيه واوروبا تهدد بحذر
المنصه
[موسيقى]
نستهل العربيه 360 من روسيا اذ بثت اذاعه
محليه عده خطابا مزعوما للرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين تحدث فيه عن غزو اوكراني
لمقاطعات حدوديه روسيه واعلن فرضا الاحكام
العرفيه قبل ان تعلن السلطات عن تعرض هذه
الاذاعات لعمليه قرصنه
حده الحرب بين روسيا واوكرانيا تصاعدت في
ميدان المعركه وعلى مستوى الاعلام اذاعه
روسيه عده تعرضت لعمليه قرصنه وبثت خطابا
زائفا للرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
الخطاب تحدث عن غزو اوكراني واعلن فرض
الاحكام العرفيه في المناطق الحدوديه كما
دعى السكان المحليين الى اخلاء مناطقهم
الخطاب اكد ان القوات الاوكرانيه المدججه
بالسلاح والمدعومه من واشنطن اجتاحت مناطق
كورسك وبالقرود وبريانسك وتحدث ايضا عن
توقيع مرسوم رئاسي قريبا يفرض تعبئه
العامه في روسيا المتحدث باسم الكرملين
قرصنه مؤكدا ان الاذاعات المعنيه عاودت
السيطره على موجات بثها رساله بوتين
المزيفه تاتي بالتزامن مع اعلان يروج
للهجوم الاوكراني المضاد تم بثه في
التلفزيون محلي بالقرم المقطع اظهر جنودا
اوكرانيين يضعون اصابعهم على شفاههم في
اشاره الى الهجوم هي حرب تستعمل فيها كل
الوسائل بما فيها الاعلاميه خاصه من
الجانب الاوكراني
وفي اخر تطورات الميدانيه اعلنت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه عن تصديها لهجوم اوكراني
بري جديد في جنوب دونيتس واكدت الدفاع
الروسيه ان القوات الاوكرانيه تنفذت هجمات
جديده في اتجاه جنوب من خلال اشراك ما يصل
الى ثلاث مجموعات تكتيكيه مشيره الى انه
تم ضبط الهجوم الاوكراني من خلال
الاجراءات النشطه للوحدات ونيران المدفعيه
والغارات الجويه وتاتي التطورات بعد ساعات
من اعلان روسيا احباط محاولات اوكرانيه
للتسلل الى اراضي مقاطعه بيلجورودا
الحدوديه
من دونيات معنا مراسل العربيه رائد الاغبر
اهلا بك معنا رائد ما ابرز ما حصل اليوم
فعلا وتم التاكد منه وصولا الى ما يجري
الان على الارض معك تفضل
طاهر مساء الخير يعني ربما يكون الهجوم
الاوكراني المضاد قد بدا بالفعل حيث
الحراك الكبير الذي تنفذه القوات
الاوكرانيه في محاور مختلفه ان كانت كما
اسلفت على المنطقه الحدوديه في بيل جراد
اعلنت الدفاع الروسيه عن احباط عمليه تسلل
للقوات الاوكرانيه لاحدى البلدات لكن
القوات الاوكرانيه كما كان في التقرير
نشرت صور وفيديوهات لهذه القوات ولقوات
مواليه مواليه لروسيا داخل احدى البلدات
في بيلجرات طبعا وكالات الانباء اكدت بان
هذه عمليات فبركه للفيديوهات والصور وكانت
تظهر بان هذه الفيديوهات صورت في شرنوبل
وليس في بيل جراد عوده
للاوضاع العسكريه ما زالت كل المناطق ان
كان الشريط الحدودي حول بيليغراد كورسكو
ومقاطعات اخرى تتعرض لقصف اوكرانيا ان كان
بالمسيرات او بالقذائف والصواريخ و
بالمئات الحديث عن بيلجرد خاصه بالمئات
المناطق والمقاطعات الاخرى ربما اعداد
فرديه او اكثر من عشره قطع او ضربات
صاروخيه لكن الهجومات المضاده التي يعني
شاهدناها خلال الاربعه وعشرين ساعه
الماضيه غير
الهجوم الاخير في جنوب دانياسك بالفعل كان
الحديث صباحا من قبل الدفاع الروسيه عن
احباط عده هجمات ان كان في باخمت او
مارنكا او حتى اوغلادار نفس المنطقه التي
شننا مرارا منها الجيش الاوكراني هجمات
مضاده تقول الدفاع الروسيه بانها نحت
المئات صباحا كان الحديث عن ثلاث مئه فتره
المساء كان الحديث عن اعداد كبيره ايضا
بالمئات من القوات الاوكرانيه قد قضت
عليهم الاله العسكريه الثقيله الروسيه
سلاح الجو كما ان عشرات الاليات قد دمرت
حسب الدفاع الروسيه هناك تطور جديد في
محور اباخ تعلن السلطات المحليه هنا
القائم باعمال
الرئاسه هنا في دانيه قال بان الوضع صعب
في باخمت تجري المعارك الضاريه في المحور
الشمالي القوات الاوكرانيه تحاول التقدم
نحو باخمه كعوده وتحاول التقدم ايضا من
الناحيه الاخرى نحو مدينه ليسيشانس التي
سيطر عليها جيش الروسي العام الماضي
بالفعل هناك هجمات كبيره في محور عقله دار
جنوب مقاطعه
الحديث عن اكثر من عشره هجمات حاولت
القوات الاوكرانيه العوده والتقدم
والسيطره على مناطق هي تحت سيطره الجانب
الروسي لكن
المقرر ويمكن له ان يستمر في الايام
المقبله لنرى ذلك معك دائما ومع بقيه
مراسلينا مراسل العربيه رائد الاكبر شكرا
جزيلا على هذه الافاده تحياتي اليك
الهجمات على الروسيه خلال الاسابيع
الماضيه اظهرت ضعف الدفاعات الروسيه بحسب
تقرير
الصحيفه قالت ان التوغلات التي تقوم بها
مجموعات روسيه معارضه اضافه للقصف المتقطع
على الاقليم قد شكل اختبارا لدفاعات الروس
قبل الهجوم المضاد المرتقب العمليات
الاخيره في باكرود دفعت موسكو الى استخدام
قوتها الجويه ومدفعيتها كما انها تزيد
الضغط على الاخيره لسحب بعض قواتها بعيدا
عن الخطوط الاماميه للقتال شرق اوكرانيا
قالت ان تركيز اوكرانيا على استهداف
المناطق الحدوديه قد يضعف بشكل ماء دفاعات
موسكو في اجزاء من خط المواجهه البالغ
طوله قرابه الفي كم رغم التحصينات
الدفاعيه التي وضعتها روسيا خلال الاشهر
الاخيره على الارض كشف فيلق المتطوعين
الروس وهو احد المجموعات المسلحه المعارضه
عن اسر جنديين روسيين وعرضت هذه المجموعه
اطلاق سراحهم مقابل اسرار اوكرانيا في
السياق اعلن يفجين بريجوجن مؤسس مجموعه
فاجنر التي قادت عمليه السيطره الروسيه
على بخنوت انه مستعد لارسال قوات لانقاذ
الاسيرين بدوره اقترح الرئيس الشيشاني
رمضان قادروف اليوم ارسال عناصر من قواته
الى القضاء على المجموعات المسلحه الروسيه
او الاوكرانيه هناك الروسيه المعارضه
الدفاعات الروسيه بمختلف المناطق هدف
لموسكو ونذكر هنا ان الرئيس الذي كان قد
دعى الاسبوع الماضي ونذكر بذلك ايضا
لتحسين الدفاع الجوي في العاصمه بعد تعرض
موسكو لهجمات بطائرات مسيره ثلاثاء الماضي
ميدانيا تعمل كل من كييف وموسكو على تكثيف
الهجمات بالصواريخ والمسيرات في محاوله
لاستنزاف الدفاعات الجويه للطرف الاخر
وابعاد القوات عن الخطوط الاماميه فيما كل
هذا ياتي مع ترقب ما بات يوصف كما قلنا
بالهجوم المضاد الذي قال الرئيس الاوكراني
ان بلاده مستعده لشنه لكنه اشار الى ان
الهجوم سيستغرق بعض الوقت وستكون تكلفته
باهظه ينضم الينا من كياف لمتابعه كل هذه
التطورات مستشار وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
يوريسك اهلا بك معنا سيد يوريك مره جديده
على شاشه العربيه هذه المجموعات التي تشن
هجمات على الحدود والتي توصف بالجماعات
مسلحه معارضه روسيه من اين تاتي ومن
يدعمها هل باتت كياف تتبنى دعم هذه
المجموعات بالتمويل والسلاح والمعلومات
اسعد الله مساءكم شكرا لدعوتي
المجموعات المسلحه التي تشيرون اليها
وهي التي تسمى بجيش
بالجيش الروسي الحر وهم مواطنون روسي
وكانوا قد قرروا ان يواجهوا حكومتهم في
ونزع السلاح في المناطق التي يعيشون فيها
وقد قالوا بانهم يرغبون بالتخلص من هذا
النظام الارهابي نحن لا نسيطر على تلك
المجموعه التي تتصرف من تلقاء نفسها
وبصوره مستقله وهي تستغل الاسلحه التي
تحصل عليها من الروس
خلال عملياتهم الهجوميه ونحن بالنسبه لنا
نرى بان هذا الجيش الحري يركز على
العمليات في المناطق الاماميه
وهناك اماكن كثيره بالنسبه لنا التي نحن
نركز عليها في مناطق اماميه الممتده على
مساحه 900 كيلو متر ونود
ان نشير انه اذا ما كان بمقدوره هذه
المجموعات المعارضه ان تتخلص من اعدائنا
في ميدان المعركه
ونعمل على انهاء الحرب وازداد الستار
السلم فهذا لا ضير فيه ولكن عندما تكون
هذه المجموعات عندما تظهر بهذه الطريقه في
هذا الوقت
باعلام اوكرانيه على ثياب عناصر مجموعتها
باللهجه التي تخاطب بها الناس
بالاسلحه الغربيه التي لديها وليس فقط من
تلك التي تغتنمها من
قتالها ضد القوات الروسيه والى ما هنالك
من اذا يمكن ان يكون قد زودها بكل ذلك ان
لم تكن اوكرانيا
فهذه حرب
واحيانا ولسوء الطالع الروس
يقومون ايضا بالحصول على بعض اسلحه
اوكرانيه في الخطوط الاماميه ما نستطيع
قوله بكل تاكيد وهنا اكرر ان تلك القوات
المتمرده هي مستقله وليست خاضعه لسيطره
القوات الاوكرانيه او للاستخبارات
الاوكرانيه والامر الوحيد الذي يفاجئنا
صراحه هو ان الامر قد استغرق منهم فتره
طويله من الزمن للتصرف ونعتقد انهم
كانوا قد
شاهدوا كيف استطاعت القوات الاوكرانيه من
الحاق الهزيمه بالروس وادركوا بان
بمقدورهم فعل ذات الشيء داخل روسيا ومن
الاشياء التي حققتها روسيا بان هذا النظام
الارهابي قد دمر مستقبل شعبه لذا بعض
هؤلاء الروس الان يقومون
بالانتفاضه على قيادتهم اذا انت تقول بان
هذه المجموعات تاتي او تستولي على سلاح من
القوات الروسيه التي تكون قد استولت عليها
احيانا من القوات الاوكرانيه في بعض
المعارك طيب هذا واضح ولكن سؤالي لك الان
محدد هل انتم مستعدون لدعم مثل هذه
المجموعات من الان فصاعدا اذا كنتم تقولون
دائما بانكم لا تفعلون ذلك الان ولكن
تسعدون يعني رؤيه مثل ذلك يحصل ضد القياده
الروسيه هل انتم مستعدون ما الذي يمنعكم
من دعمهم بالمال بالسلاح بالمعلومات
مستعدون وسوف نستمر في دعم القوات
الاوكرانيه
لدينا مهمه جسيمه امامنا لابد لنا من
تحرير مناطقنا من هؤلاء الارهابيين وان
نحاسبهم ولعلكم سمعتم بانه 38 دوله في
كافه انحاء العالم قد عبرت عن استعدادها
لاقامه محاكمه حرب دوليه من اجل محاسبه
النظام الارهابي في روسيا فهذه هي الجهات
التي سوف ندعمها سوف ندعم جنودنا روسيا هي
بلد كبير
باكثر من ثمانين مليون نسمه من السكان
ومتاكد بان بعض الاشخاص الذين موجودونهم
موجودون في داخل روسيا قد يناصرون قضيتنا
ومستقبلنا
اذا نصروا قضيتكم هل يمكن لكم ان تدعموهم
هل يمكن ان توافقوا على دعم هؤلاء هل نقش
هذا الموضوع في اجتماعاتكم هل هناك جناح
اوكراني يؤيد هذا الدعم على الاقل
الاحترام يبدو بانك قد قررت السؤال بطريقه
مختلفه والان يجب علي ان اجيب بنفس
الطريقه هؤلاء هم مواطنون روس مستقلين
وكنا قد راينا في بدايه الحرب الاهليه في
روسيا ما حدث نحن نركز على دعم قواتنا
والعسكريه الخاصه بنا لانه لدينا الكثير
من المعارك التي تجري في بخمس ومارينكا
وافديكا وعلى الخطوط الاماميه الاخرى نعم
لدينا نفس العدو نتشاطر بنفس العدو الا
وهو
القياده في روسيا وهؤلاء المواطن الروس
غير سعداء بالعمليات الارهابيه والجرائم
والويلات التي يرتكبها بوتين ونظامه وفي
ذات الوقت اننا لسنا جزءا من هذه المجموعه
لديهم اجندتهم الخاصه ونحن لدينا عدونا
المشترك الذي نقاتله
ورغم يعني ما تفضلت به الا انه الحديث
مستمر عن وج عملاء لاوكرانيا في داخل
روسيا نفذت بعض العمليات سنشير الى بعض
هذه الاخبار ونعود بها اليك لنسالك عنها
استاذ يوريسك ارجو ان تتفضل بالبقاء معنا
فقد قالت مصادر استخباراتيه لسي ان ان
اوكرانيا جندت عملاء داخل روسيا وتمنحهم
طائرات مسيره لشن هجمات من داخل التراب
الروسي مضيفه ان هؤلاء العملاء داخل روسيا
يمكن ان يكونوا قد نفذوا هجوم المسيرات
على الكرملين في اوائل شهر مايو الماضي
نتابع
[موسيقى]
الحرب خدعه وتكتيكات القصف بهذه الطريقه
التقليديه ربما اصبح من الماضي او لنقل
يجب ان توازيه خطه مبتكره فكلما ابدعت
طرقا جديده للقتال زاد حظك للتقدم في
ميدان المواجهه
يبدو ان اوكرانيا تعلمت الدرس جيدا بعد
اكثر من عام وثلاثه اشهر على بدايه الحرب
كياف اقامت شبكه من العملاء والمتعاطفين
داخل روسيا للعمل على تنفيذها هجمات ضد
اهداف روسيه عبر المسيرات وفق مصادر
مخابراتيه
العملاء الموالون لاوكرانيا داخل روسيا
نفذوا هجوم المسيرات على الكرملين في
اوائل شهر مايو الماضي فعمليه الاطلاق تمت
من داخل روسيا بدلا من اوكرانيا تجاه
موسكو المسؤولون الامريكيون يعتقدون ان
اوكرانيا طورت خلايا داخل روسيا تتكون من
مزيج من المؤيدين لاوكرانيا ونشطاء مدربين
تدريبا جيدا في هذا النوع من الحروب
معلومات سي ان ان تشير الى ان اوكرانيا
انشات طرق تهريب خلف خطوط العدو يمكن
استخدامها لارسال طائرات بدون طيار او
مكوناتها الى داخل روسيا حيث يمكن تجميعها
هناك بعد ذلك
عملائكيه يعتقد انه يتم تزويدهم بطائرات
بدون طيار اوكرانيه الصنع دون استعمال
المسيرات التي سلمتها واشنطن المصادر تشير
ايضا الى انه ليس من الواضح ما اذا كانت
هجمات مسيرات اخرى نفذت في الايام الاخيره
من خلالها هؤلاء العملاء خاصه الهجوم الذي
استهدف حيا سكانيا بالقرب من موسكو وضربه
اخرى على مصاف النفط جنوبي روسيا هي
مواجهه عسكريه كل شيء فيها مباح وابتكار
الاساليب الجديده اصبح اوكرانيا بامتياز
بالنظر الى قوه الاله العسكريه الروسيه في
المواجهات التقليديه بلال الوجداني
العربيه
لدي هذه المعلومات
واجبتك على سؤالك فلعلي سوف اقل من عملي
بعد هذه المقابله هذه مساله لا يمكن البوح
فيها لانه اولا في اوكرانيا هناك
قسم مختص في العمليات الاستخباريه وهو يضم
مجموعه من الخبراء المتمرسين وانت تطلب
مني ان اوميط اللثام
لذلك هناك طرق اخرى يصعب لتوجيه السؤال
دائما سؤالي الثاني بطريقه اخرى هل تشعرون
ان لديكم الحق بان يكون لديكم عملاء في
الداخل الروسي يستهدفون الاراضي الروسيه
بموجب الماده الواحده والخمسين بموجب
ميثاق الامم المتحده في ان اي دوله تكون
ضحيه لعدوان من حقها الدفاع عن نفسها في
تطبيق احكام هذه الماده وبصوره واضحه
بموجب هذا الحقل الممنوح لكل دوله وعضو في
الامم المتحده فهناك يمكن تنفيذ الجمله من
العمليات لكن لانه نؤكده لشركائنا
وحلفائنا وهذا ما فعلناه في مناسبات
متعدده باننا سوف نعمل ونحن عازمون على
تحرير المناطق الاوكرانيه هذا هو الامر
الذي سوف يتم بتطبيق كافه القدرات المتاحه
لنا سواء كان الامر يطال عمليات سريه فهذه
منطقه حرب وانت تعلم اجابه هذا السؤال
بنفسك
يعني اجابه على الاقل في نهايتها فيها
الكثير من الصراحه وارجو ان لا تتسبب
باقالتك من عملك شكرا جزيلا لك مستشار
وزير الدفاع الاوكراني يوريساك من كياف
تحياتي اليك شكرا على مشاركتك معنا الليله
[موسيقى]
في العربيه 360 ايضا
الكاميرات لمواقع نوويه في ايران لكن
طموحنا اكبر
[موسيقى]
ما زلنا نعتقد ان الدبلوماسيه هي افضل
طريقه لمنع ايران من الحصول على سلاح نووي
بشكل يمكن التحقق منه وفعال ومستدام
وبالتوازي مع ذلك فان الضغط والرد على
الاقتصاديين يعززان دبلوماسيتنا اذا رفضت
ايرانو طريق الدبلوماسيه فعندئذ كما اوضح
الرئيس بايدن مرارا وتكرارا فان جميع
الخيارات مطروحه على الطاوله لضمان عدم
حصول ايران على اسلحه نوويه
قال المدير العام للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه رفع الجرافسي ان مخزون ايران من
اليورانيوم المخصب ارتفع باكثر من الربع
في ثلاثه اشهر موضحا ان مخزون ايران من
اليورانيوم المخصب بنسبه 60% تجاوز مئه
كيلو جرام كما اشار الى انه تم اعاده
تركيب كاميرات المراقبه في مواقع نوويه
بايران واكد في الوقت عينه ان الوكاله
كانت تطمح لاكثر من ذلك
معنى من طهران عبر سكايب مصدق فور الكاتب
والاستاذ في العلوم السياسيه اهلا بكم
معنا من واشنطن حسين عبد الحسين البحث في
مؤسسه الدفاع عن الديمقراطيات اهلا بكم
معنا استاذ حسين ايضا
وابدا معك استاذ حسين لماذا تعتقد بان
الحديث عاد الان عن هذا الموضوع والى اي
مدى ترى انفراجا على صعيد اي مفاوضات
قادمه يمكن ان تبدا بخطوات حصونيه مثل ما
حصل
مساء الخير انا اعتقد انه الكره هي منذ
فتره في ملعب ايران انه الولايات المتحده
قدمت كل ما لديها وهي مستعده للتواصل
الاتفاقيه وايران لاسباب متنوعه لم تشا
التوصل اما اعاده احياء الاتفاقيه الماضيه
او
التواصل الاتفاقيه جديده هذه المره طهران
تتحرك لا اعرف فعليا ما هي الدوافع ربما
تخشى انه اقتربت الانتخابات الرئاسيه
الامريكيه وقد لا ياتي رئيس
يريد التوصل لاتفاقيه مثل بايدن او لاسباب
اخرى داخليه او اقليميه لا نعرفها ترى
انها تنازلت قدمت تنازلات الان لكي تعود
الى هذا السياق الذي كانت فيه الذي رفضته
سابقا اذا
اعتقد انها صارت اكثر مرونه في الماضي كان
هناك بعض النقاط العالقه منها تعهد ايراني
بعدم الانتقام
لمقتل سليماني وذلك يكون عاده يعني
محاوله قتل الامريكيين
والموضوع الثاني كان اصرار ايران على رفع
الحرس الثوري الايراني عن لائحه العقوبات
الايرانيه وطبعا الولايات المتحده قالت
انه حتى في الاتفاقيه الاولى في زمن
اوباما كانت الاتفاقيه هي حول الموضوع
النووي فقط ولم تتعلق باي مواضيع ترتبط
بالارهاب يبدو انه ايران ابدت مرونه في
هذا الموضوع ناخذ راي استاذ مصدق ما
تعليقك على هذا الكلام انه ايران ادت
مرونه الان وبدات بخطوات حسن
نيه لانها تستشعر لحظه امريكيه معينه يجب
ان تقدم معها بعضا من المرونه ما رايك
نعم شكرا تحياتي انا اعتقد يعني ثواني انا
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه نحن نسمع
اليوم يعني لينكن ايضا قبله
ايضا وكذلك قاده ايران يعني جميع يتحدث عن
دبلوماسيه بانه الوحيد ايران طبعا هي
دائما كانت تدعو الى دبلوماسيه الامريكيين
ايضا كانوا يدعون ولكن كانت الخطوط تتشارك
احيانا ولا تصل الى نتيجه انا اعتقد يعني
هناك تطورات كبيره جدا يعني بدات تحصل
ببساطه عمانيه يعني هناك غموض كبير حول
هذه الاساتذه ولكن نحن نشهد يعني بوادر
هذه الوساطه سواء لدى الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه
التي فتحتها ضد ايران او من الجانب
الامريكي انا اعتقد يعني اعتقد اولا
بالنسبه للاتفاق المبرم في عام 2015
هذا الاتفاق يعني اصبح ميتا تماما يعني
على الاتفاق بعد سنه سوف ينتهي مفعوله
يعني كل البنود الوارده في هذا الاتفاق
فبالتالي لكن هل ايران قادره على قرض
شروطها الان تلك التي كانت تضعها على اي
اتفاق يتم التفاوض عليه خاصه فيما يتعلق
بالحرس الثوري
او فيما يتعلق بالافراج عن الاموال او
فيما يتعلق بالنسب المتعلقه بالنووي
انا اعتقد يعني موضوع الحرس وموضوع الامور
الشائكه الاخرى اعتقد يعني جانبا يعني
استغنى عن هذا الموضوع لم نعد نسمع اليوم
هذا الحديث انا اعتقد يعني هناك اتفاق
حاليا ببساطه عمانيه غير معلن عنه وغير
رسمي
ينص على خفض التوتر بين ايران والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ولكن هذا يتطلب التنازل
من جانب طهران اليس كذلك ليس هناك موضوع
تنازلي اساسا يعني ليس ايران يعني ماذا
تقدم حتى تنازل يعني
مستمره واذا هي رفعت يعني نسبه التخصيب
وهذا يعني هذا
الجانب المقابل خرج من الاتفاق الاوروبي
ايضا وبقيه الاعضاء الموجودين في هذه
الاتفاقيه المبرمه في عام 2015 الكل
تنزلوا عن عن اداء التزاماتهم وبالتالي
يعني هذا الاتفاق لا قيمه له وانا اعتقد
يعني هناك تفاق جديد اضافي دراساته عمانيه
وخفض التوتر وربما سيستمر العمل به على
مراحل ولمده عامين حتى تتحقق الثقه واذا
ما تحققت الثقه سوف يتم التوقيع على هذه
الاتفاقيه ولكن دعنا ناخذ راي استاذ حسين
لنرى ما هي المواقف الامريكيه ما هي
السقوف الامريكيه المقبول بها لكي توقع
اتفاقا جديدا مع طهران في موضوع النووي
طبعا يعني لا نتوقع ان تكون الاتفاقيه
مطابقه بالضبط لما جرى في اتفاقيه العام
2015 اي انه لن يعني لا تذهب الدولتان الى
عمان ثم يكون وساطه ثم يعني الخطوات لن
تكون هي نفسها ولكن ما نعرفه حتى الان هو
انه الحديث هو عن اتفاقيه اصغر من
الاتفاقيه العام 2015 وان كنا نتذكر انه
اتفاقيه 2015 ايضا سبقتها اتفاقيه كانت
اصغر منها فيبدو ان هناك عوده للاتفاقيه
الاصغر كجزء من مراحل بناء الثقه ولكن
بناء الثقه بعد عامين الموضوع ليس مضموما
مضمونا طبعا نحن سمعنا في الجولات الماضيه
انه طهران طلبت من واشنطن تقديم ضمانات
انها لن تنسحب الجوله القادمه طبعا وهذه
الضمانات تحتاج الكونجرس والكونجرس من
المستحيل ان يوافق على استاذ مصدقه هل
تعتقدون بانه ايران يمكن ان تحصل على هكذا
ضمانات من الجانب الام ريكي اذا ما تغيرت
الاداره وهل هذا شرط حالي
انا اعتقد يعني هذه الضمانات ايمان متفهمه
هذه ضمانات غير ممكنه اعتقد هذا كان في
صلب المحادثات عبر الوسيطه العمانيه يعني
ولكن بالنسبه لايران يعني سوف لن تخسر
شيئا يعني حاليا بموجب هذا الاتفاق
الاضافي سوف تتراجع عن بعض الخطوات
الاضافيه التي قامت بها فيما يتعلق
بالتخصيب والتعاون الجاد مع الوكاله
الدولي للطاقه الذريه
والاثنان ايضا ينتظران الانتخابات
الامريكيه اذا جاء شخص اخر غير الرئيس
بايدن واراد خروج من هذا الاتفاق هذا
الشيء لا يضر ايبان ايبان لديها الاجهزه
ولديها الامكانيات وستعود الى المربع
الاول يعني هذا كل ما في الامر وكل ما
فهمته وكل ما تسرب
من بعض الاروقه وبالتالي انا اعتقد يعني
ولكن كيف يمكن لك ان تتحدث سابقا عن الثقه
في ظل نوايا من هذا النوع في في حال اي
تغيير حصل على الاداره الامريكيه وكانه اي
اتفاق نووي هو محصور فقط بشخص الرئيس
الامريكي او من يتسلم اي حزب يتسلم في
رئاسه الامريكا في اطار الحرب الدائره
المستمره منذ زمن بعيد بين البلدين مع انه
ابعاده اكبر بكثير
وفعلا يعني هي مشكله يعني المشكله
الاساسيه اسرائيل وهناك الابيات يعني في
داخل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هناك ضغط
على الاداره الديمقراطيه وبالتالي يعني
هذا الشيء وارد يعني
يجب ان تنظر الى هذا الاتفاق فانه اتفاق
مرحله اتفاق صغير اتفاق يقرا مع تيار خاص
في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه على اساس
تبادل المصالح يعني نعود الى موضوع
اسرائيل
مجددا الى دفه استاذ حسين عبد الحسين لكي
يدقق لنا اكثر في هذا الموضوع
لا اعتقد انه اسرائيل هي المعارض الوحيد
لهذه الاتفاقيه اعتقد اعتقد ان هناك اكثر
من حليف للولايات المتحده حول العالم يخشى
من هذه الاتفاقيه وهناك طبعا الغالبيه في
الكونغرس من الحزبين وليس من الحزب
الجمهوري وحده تخشى تقول انه الاتفاقيه
الاولى اصلا يعني لو كانت كافيه لما كنا
احتجنا الى العوده مرارا لانه مجرد خروجه
الولايات المتحده من الاتفاقيات
ظهر انه لم يتم تفكيك اي بنيه تحتيه يعني
للتخصيب قامت ايران فقط بتجميد التخصيب
واعتقد انه هذا الموضوع لا يناسب الكونجرس
لا يناسب غالبيه انه ان دخلنا في اتفاقيه
تكون اتفاقيه دائمه ولكن لا تكون اتفاقيه
تحت الرحمه الايرانيه انه الايران يعني
غيرت تتغير الاتفاقيه فاعتقد انه سنعود
الى هذه هذا الاخذ والرد بين الاداره
والكونجرس واعتقد انه الرئيس الامريكي قد
يضطر الى الانفاق من رصيده السياسي ان كان
داخل العاصمه الامريكيه او ان كان مع بعض
الحلفاء خارج الولايات المتحده للسير في
هذه الاتفاقيه التي الارجح انه لن ترضي
الكثيرين شكرا جزيلا لكما الكاتب والاستاذ
في العلوم سياسيه من طهران شكرا الاستاذ
حسين عبد الحسين البحث في مؤسسه الدفاع
الديمقراطيات من واشنطن تحياتي اليكما
[موسيقى]
يوم واحد يفصل الكويت عن انتخابات مجلس
الامه امه عشرين ثلاثه وعشرين المقرر
انطلاقها يوم غد
249 مرشحا سيخوضون السباق نحو المقاعد
النيابيه وهو ادنى عدد للمرشحين منذ العام
منذ انتخابات العام 2008 وتاتي هذه
الانتخابات بعد حل مجلس الامه مرتين
وابطاله مره واحده خلال اقل من عامين ووسط
ازمه مستمره بين الحكومه والبرلمان
كيف تعيش الكويت ليلتها الاخيره قبل
الانتخابات هذه مع مراسله العربيه من
الكويت شهد المتروك اهلا بك شاهد اذا كيف
يتابع الكويتيون يعني ليلتهم قبيل هذه
الانتخابات حديثهم ودواوينهم توقعات
الاقبال ونسب يعني التي سيحصل عليها
المرشحون في هذه الانتخابات معك
نعم طاهر طبعا اليوم هو يوم الاثنين اليوم
الذي يسبق الانتخابات او يوم الاقتراع وهو
يوم الصمت الانتخابي بحيث ان الناخبين او
عفوا المرشحين لا يسمح لهم بالظهور
اعلاميا او تقديم اي ندوات انتخابيه هو
يوم صمت انتخابي يتيح للناخب بالتفكير في
من سيختار في يوم الاقتراع المزمع عقده
يوم غد الثلاثاء طبعا ابواب الاقتراع
ستفتح الساعه الثامنه صباحا وتستمر لمده
12 ساعه لغايه الساعه الثامنه مساء مساء
الاستعدادات يعني على جميع او على جميع
الاصعده من وزارات حتى وزاره التربيه خصصت
عشر مدرسه وحولتها الى مركز اقتراع ايضا
وزاره العدل خصصت نحو
759 لجنه ما بين رئيسيه وفرعيه ايضا هناك
عدد 700 او نحو 794 الف
المفترض ان يتوجهون يوم غد للادلاء
باصواتهم طبعا
ربما كما ذكرت ان العدد المرشحين هو
الادنى منذ عام 2008 فقط مرشحين ومرشحه
حتى هذا ما يعني لاحظناه او من ملاحظات
حتى الناخبين من خلال الاستطلاع الراي
الذي عملناه اليوم وسالنا بعض المواطنين
ما اذا كانوا سيصوتون او لا لم يكن الحماس
مثل الحماس الاعوام او الانتخابات الماضيه
بسبب يعني حل المجلس اكثر من مره بطلانه
ايضا اكثر من مره لذلك صحيح هناك سيكون
هناك اقبال ممكن من المواطنين والمواطنات
بالذهاب لمراكز الاقتراع والتصويت لكن ليس
بذات الحماس في الانتخابات السابقه ايضا
طهر يعني رحله طويله شاهدها مجلس الامه ما
بين حل وبطلان ايضا عملت عليه عرض خلال
وجودي ايضا في استديوهات العربيه
يحكي قصه اسباب بطلان وحل المجلس ممكن ان
نتابعه معكم
[موسيقى]
كل اربع سنوات تقام انتخابات لمجلس الامه
الكويتي الا انه ليس بالضروره ان يلتزم
بها لاسباب عده الحل وعدم التعاون هما
اكثر اسباب عدم اكمال مجلس الامه مدته
الدستوريه فمنذ العام
1963 وفي اول انتخابات اجريت في تاريخ
الكويت والى اليوم حل مجلس الامه تسع مرات
لاسباب تتراوح بين عدم تعاون بين المجلس
والحكومه او حتى لتراكم المشاريع
والقوانين وتازم الموقف ما بين السلطتين
وكثره الاستجوابات البطلان هو سبب اخر
لعدم استمراريه مجلس الامه في عقد جلساته
فخلال 19 مجلسا منتخبا حكمت المحكمه
الدستوريه ببطلان المجلسي ثلاث مرات الاول
لمجلس 2012 وعوده مجلس 2009 الذي تم حله
اصلا وكان الحل لم يكن والذي اعتبر انذاك
سابقه في تاريخ مجلس الامه الحكم نصا على
بطلان العمليه الانتخابيه لمجلس 2012 وعدم
صحه عضويه النواب وتم دعوه الناخبين
للاقتراع من جديد حكم البطلان الثاني جاء
في 2013 لمجلس 2012 وتحصين مرسوم الصوت
الواحد الذي اثار جدلا في شارع الكويتي
ورفض المعارضه له ومقاطعتها للانتخابات
واخيرا مجلس
2022 الذي استمر لسته اشهر فقط حيث ابطل
لوجود تناقضات في مرسوم حل لمجلس 2020 ما
يعني تكرر سيناريو مجلسي 2012
و2009 رغم تاكيد المحكمه الدستوريه ان
الاراده الساميه بحل المجالس قائمه على
الاسس الموضوعيه
[موسيقى]
توعد الاتحاد الاوروبي بمحاسبه كافه
المسؤولين عن الانتهاكات والتجاوزات لحقوق
الانسان في السودان بعد رصد تجاوزات عده
ميدانيه وحتى الاتحاد الاوروبي في بيان
طرفي الصراع في السودان على وقف الاعمال
القتاليه على الفور وافساح المجال
الاستئناف عمليه انتقال سياسي شامله ذات
مصداقيه مضيفا ان العمل متواصل مع جميع
الجهات الاقليميه والدوليه المعنيه بما في
ذلك الاتحاد الافريقي والممثل الخاص
للامين العام للامم المتحده في السودان
لتحقيق تلك الاهداف
الى ذلك قلم ممثل السودان لدى الامم
المتحده الحارس ادريس انه يجب القضاء على
ما سماه تمرد الدعم السريع للوصول الى
عمليه سياسيه سليمه واضاف ادريس من
السودان منفتح على كافه المبادرات الخيره
والبناءه لاعاده الوضع الانساني والمسار
الحياتي الى طبيعته لكنه يرفض اي شكل من
اشكال التدخل الدولي حيث طالب الامم
المتحده بادانه هذا التمرد على حد وصفه
[موسيقى]
وتتابعون معنا ايضا في العربيه 360 بعد
تغيبه عن المحكمه في قضيه انتهاك الصحافه
لخصوصيته الامير هاري يستعد للمطول غدا في
شهاده تاريخيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد قدم مايك بانس نائب رئيس
الامريكي سابق دونالد ترامب رسميا اوراقه
ترشحه لرئاسه الامريكيه عام 20/24 كان
برنس اعلن بوقت سابق نيته الترشح عن الحزب
الجمهوري ليكون منافسا لرئيسه السابق
ترامب ومن المنتظر بحسب وسائل اعلام
امريكيه ان ينشر مايك تفاصيل حملته خلال
اليومين المقبلين
[موسيقى]
يدقق اربعه اعضاء في مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي
في امتثال منصه تويتر التي يديرها ايلون
ماسك لمعايير الخصوصيه ووجه الاعضاء رساله
الى ماسك مفادها بان سلوكه يكشف عن لا
مبالاه واضحه تجاه الالتزامات القانونيه
طويله الامد على تويتر والتي لم تختفي
عندما تولى الشركه وطلب الاعضاء من ماسك
توضيح مدى التزامات لجنه التجاره
الفيدراليه على تويتر وما اذا كانت
تسريحات العمال والاستقالات قد اعاقت
قدرتها على الامتثال
اقل من ثلاثه اشهر امام تويتر للتغريد في
السماء الاوروبيه فقرروا المنصه الخروج من
ميثاق الاتحاد الاوروبي لمكافحه التضليل
قد يفقدها احد ابرز شرائح جمهورها لاسيما
انها تشكل او احدى ابرز هذه الشرائح
لاسيما انها تشكل احدى ابرز المنصات في
تشكيل الراي العام الاوروبي التفاصيل في
هذا التقرير
قبل بضعه ايام وبتغريده من ثلاث كلمات
حذرت نائبه رئيس المفوضيه الاوروبيه للقيم
والشفافيه تويتر من الحظر في الاتحاد
الاوروبي قائله وداعا ايها الطائر تحذير
يبدو انه قريب من التطبيق بحق الطائر
الازرق
لقد اختارت تويتر الطريقه الصعب اختار
المواجهه من خلال الخروج من مدونه ممارسات
التضليل الاوروبيه الطبيعيه التي تضع
القواعد الاساسيه لقانون الاتحاد بشان
الخدمات الرقميه المدونه التي اعلنت تويتر
نيته الانسحاب منها كان الاتحاد الاوروبي
قد اطلقها عام 2018 حيث ستدخل حيز التنفيذ
في 25 من اغسطس لاجبار المنصات على مكافحه
المعلومات المضلله اذ تنص على وجه الخصوص
بوجوب ازاله المحتوى غير القانوني وحظر
الاعلانات التي تستهدف القاصرين وبفرض
غرامات تصل الى سته في المئه من حجم
الاعمال على المنصات التي لا تم هذه
القواعد
الاتحاد الاوروبي يعتبر المدونه بمثابه
ميثاق لمكافحه المعلومات المضلله في
الفضاء الالكتروني حيث وقع عليه ما يقرب
من 30 موقعا من بينها مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي الكبرى مثل ميتا وتويتر وتيك
توك الى جانب جوجل ومايكروسوفت التهديد
بالحظر لم يكن الاول على لسان جروفا فقد
سبقها الى ذلك الوزير الفرنسي المفوض
للشؤون الرقميه الا ان الاخير اعرب عن
قلقه بشان التنظيم الاوروبي المفرط في
مجال الذكاء الاصطناعي في المستقبل معتبرا
موقف البرلمان الاوروبي مبالغا فيه لكونه
يفرض التزامات تدقيق والتزامات شفافيه
مفرطه بالنسبه لهذا النوع من النماذج وبين
التهديد بالحظر وتطبيقه قرابه ثلاثه اشهر
امام الطائر الازرق للتغريد في السماء
الاوروبيه تغريد ان سكت سيؤثر على نقاشات
الراي العام بحسب الوزير الفرنسي لكن الم
علومات المضلله تهديد للديمقراطيه
الاوروبيه
[موسيقى]
في لندن استمع قاضي المحكمه العليا الى
افادات فريقي الدفاع والادعاء في افتتاح
جلسات قضيه رفعها الامير هاري ضد ناشر
صحيفه ميرور بجمع معلومات خاصه عنه واخرين
نشرتها الصحف الصحيفه بطرق غير شرعيه تشمل
قرصنه هاتفه ورسائله وسيظهر الامير هاري
الابن الاصغر للملك تشارلز الثالث على
منصه شهود في المحكمه ليصبح اول افراد
العائله المالكه الذي يدلي بافادته منذ
130 عاما
[موسيقى]
عشرات القنوات المحليه والدوليه امام
المحكمه العليا في لندن تتابع مقاضات
الامير هاري وشخصيات مشهوره لصحيفه ميرور
لنشرها معلومات عنهم بشكل غير قانوني
لكن بعد كل الانتظار لم ترصد الكاميرات
وصول الامير هاري لغيابه عن الجلسه
الافتتاحيه في المحكمه لاسباب تتعلق بعرض
بيانات وادله تتطلب يوما كاملا بحسب
محاميه وهو ما اعتبره فريق الدفاع صحيفه
ميرور مضيعه للوقت خصوصا وانه يريد
التدقيق في ادله المرافعه باستجواب الامير
هاري كشاهد لدحض ادعاءاته بان نشر
معلوماته كانت بطرق غير شرعيه
سواء ربح او خسر القضيه فهو يريد احراج
وسائل الاعلام وبعض افراد العائله المالكه
من خلال هذه المحاكمه فهذه بالنسبه له
حمله يصر على قيادتها فيما يعتقد الاخرون
انه هوس مرضي
الامير هذه اختار المواجهه والادلاء
بافادته كاول شاهد لفرد من العائله
الملكيه منذ اكثر من قرن من الزمن يحمل
الصحف الشعبيه مسؤوليه مقتل والده ديانا
واضطراب علاقته بالعائله المالكه التي ذبت
على التجنب المحاكم لمنع الادلاء بشهادتها
بشان امور قد تكون محرجه يوم تاريخي في
القضاء البريطاني عندما يدلي الامير هاري
بشهادته في المحكمه وقد يكشف المزيد من
اسرار العائله المالكه ليعمق خلافته معها
ومخالفه التقليد بمقابضات الصحيفه على ما
يزعم ضد رغبات والدي الملك تشارلز الذي
يقضي اجازه خاصه في رومانيا
لندن بمشهد غير اعتيادي شهدت مدينه الباحه
جنوب غرب السعوديه تساقطا للثلوج رغم
اقتراب موسم الصيف الحار نتابع
[موسيقى]
والى تصريح اليوم في العربيه 360 كلما زاد
العدد زاد المرح هكذا علق الرئيس الامريكي
السابق والمرشح الجمهوري للانتخابات
الرئاسيه المرشح المحتمل دونالد ترامب على
تقارير تفيد بان عدد المرشحين الرئيسيين
في الانتخابات التمهيديه للحزب الجمهوري
سيصل الى عشره اشخاص بحلول الاربعاء يذكر
ان ترامب متقدم على ابرز منافسيه حاكم
فلوريدا
بنحو 30 نقطه بحسب استطلاعات الرايه
اما صوره اليوم
يوما ما كانت ارضا وفيره بالمياه العذبه
اما الان فاصبحت قاحله انها اهوار البصره
جنوب العراق التي ضمتها اليونسكو الى
قائمه التراث العالمي قبل ست سنوات اليوم
باتت تعاني من جفاف ادى لنفوق الاسماك
وتسبب بموجات هجره للسكان ورغم اعلان
الحكومه عن خطط للحد من الجفاف الا ان
متخصصين حذروا من كارثه بيئيه بسبب انحسار
مناطق المياه العميقه
انهيار جسر قيد الانشاء حدث قد يبدو عاديا
لكنه سيصبح استثنائيا اذا علمت ان الجسر
انهار للمره الثانيه خلال اشهر عده فقط
فيديو اليوم من ولايه بهار شرق الهند حيث
انهار جسر قيد الانشاء على نهر الغنج
بعدما سقط في ابريل من العام الماضي
واعيدت محاوله تشييده بتكلفه
ملايين دولار وبينما فتحت السلطات تحقيقا
سريعا في ملابسات الحادث اثارت مشاهد تصدع
الجسر وانهياره امام اعين المواطنين جدلا
حول الفساد وسوء الاداره في الهند
نصل الى ختام العربيه 360 والان الى اخبار
الساعه مع ميسون مؤيد اهلا بك ميسون وابرز
الملفات التي لديك الليله مساء الخير طاهر
سنبدا من تصريحات قائد فاجنر بانه ايضا
فقدوا منطقه في بخموت ايضا الموضوع الثاني
هناك اشتباكات عنيفه حقيقه في دارفورد
ايضا تعيينات اردوغان توحي بانه سيتخلى عن
سياساته الاقتصاديه السابقه بالاضافه الى
بان الاتحاد الاوروبي يحذر من خطوره
الذكاء الاصطناعي والعديد ايضا من الملفات
نامل ان تتابعنا ان شاء الله تفضلي
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات